Lillard boy outside knocks down the
first raid from long range to start
again look at this shot this is starting
the ballgame
look how far he was this is a great
screener and roller a good pass by
Westbrook running start by real respect
little it says it's like two dogs
fighting the way they go at each other
McCallum gets his first look - three
[Applause]
short roll pocket pass right here and
this is where Cantor's lack of length
Billy hurts him he was back in front of
Adams good ball movement here - McCullum
back out Lillard checks the three-point
line now sir what's Brooke to the basket
first field goal first points for
Russell Westbrook
jorts stolen by Lillard Westbrook
Clemson Westbrook for three bound the
head of steam down the court plays
enough pins he pump up the floor after
driving the rebound in about four
seconds we'll get into the [ __ ] good
defense and make a play gets all the way
to the cup and finish line first
landfall sweet move from Damian Lillard
fifth rebound to go along with six
points and six assists drives inside
quick move left handed Russell West
stella first half allow his team to
climb back into this ball game over enes
kanter Lillard again long distance
except for hey well it's three for play
from downtown somehow you guard out the
thirty feet thunders defense has really
gotten good this quarter nice feed
inside and George finally sees them go
through the roof comes living as Mark
mentioned scoreless since that first
quarter falling away there it goes
three players in double figures for the
Blazers Kanter and the backcourt
Westbrook drives and finishes because
it's the elephant in the room we need to
discuss it get past it as Westbrook with
another finish but on the fact that we
we fell short of our goal goes hard and
Adams bad shot Lillard gets to his
favored left-hand bar closes the next
guy he's just split Portland's
trembley's has picked them up certainly
was not the Chow the valuable addition
is Westbrook knocks that one day
[Applause]
Lillard for this superstar point gone
Dane dollar shout-out congratulations to
the legend Tiger Woods
reject the spectacular job westbrook
banks it all true der chasing Lillard
Irvine the backstops tough shot the
paint bounces around the rabbit chops in
how to win on the road
despite this is a pistol performance
from three-point range
West Coast banks it on the rhythm you
get Westbrook going to the basket Adams
on the roll trying to get Portland going
Willard slacking off over lilyc allows
him to shoot the basketball he must not
know the rules
hand down man down this is bad defense
he's worried about the other